Long distance sailors,
who brave months alone at sea,
tend to report that
their greatest challenge
is the soul-destroying loneliness.
We're prone to feeling lonely
when we're socially isolated,
but we can also feel lonely
when we're not isolated,
when we're in relationships
with people who care about us.
So, what is that "terrible loneliness,"
as philosopher
Bertrand Russell puts it,
where "one shivering consciousness
looks over the rim of the world
into the cold,
unfathomable, lifeless abyss."
Loneliness is the unwelcome feeling
that we lack companions,
that we have fewer or poorer
relationships than we want.
Feeling lonely is like feeling pain,
thirst and fear.
It triggers our
"fight or flight" response.
In small doses,
loneliness can help us.
It can prod us to reach out
to other people,
but when loneliness becomes
chronic and acute, it's corrosive.
Some of us turn to drugs
to deal with loneliness.
Some of us join abusive
relationships or gangs.
It's correlated with health risks
such as depression, reduced immunity,
and even suicidal behaviour.
Studies indicate that
young people feel lonely
as often as older people do.
Even young children
can feel deep loneliness.
If loneliness is a serious
social problem,
what do we do about it?
Can we have a right not to be lonely?
We cannot have a right
against feeling lonely,
but we could have rights against
some of the underlying conditions
that tend to cause loneliness.
Such as a right not to be
persistently socially isolated,
including a right not to be left
to fend for ourselves
}when we need help to stay social,
like the physically impaired person
}who needs some help
to get out of the house.
Although this isn't currently
an explicit right
in international agreements,
arguably it should be,
because human rights are about
the brute moral minimum
that we owe each other
as human beings.
In addition to talking about rights,
we can work individually to alleviate
our own and each other's loneliness.
There is value in small
social connections,
like the visit to the doctor,
the ride on the bus,
and the trip to the grocery shop.
We can make it a habit,
as writer George Monbiot suggests,
to start conversations
with people we don't know.
These micro-moments
of connection aren't just nice,
according to social psychologist
Barbara Fredrickson,
they change us for the better,
emotionally and physically.
It's like getting exercise.
And it goes both ways,
our heart's capacity for love obeys
the biological law: Use it or lose it.
As children's singer
Charlotte Diamond puts it:
Give four hugs a day -
that's the minimum, not the maximum.
Thanks for watching! :)
Don’t forget to subscribe and click the bell to receive notifications for new videos. See you again soon!